[Music]
it is that time again America's election
headquarters one of president Trump's
most outspoken Republican critics may be
getting ready to try to do something
about his dissatisfaction
Arizona Senator Jeff Flake made an
appearance today that many interpret as
the start of a possible primary
challenge to the president of course
planner Peter Doocy has the story
tonight from Manchester New Hampshire at
a famous New Hampshire event called
politics and eggs
Arizona's Republican Senator Jeff Flake
cracked open the door to a presidential
campaign Lake didn't propose any new
policies today instead he mostly just
warned of his party's ideals slipping
away in the age of Trump voters in New
Hampshire historically favored the
candidates who visit most frequently so
flake is already trying to establish
early state street cred by talking up
his friendship with someone who's
already won two New Hampshire primaries
for months flake has been trying to
steer his party away from members he
deems too controversial come the party
of Roy Moore and Donald Trump we already
have the post and that comment in the
fall earned him a presidential nickname
flaky which followed a summertime
dismissal of the senator as irrelevant
nobody knows who the hell he is
the RNC is already dismissing flakes
chances of dooming Trump's chance at a
second term telling Fox quote President
Trump won because of his vision to make
America great again and we're confident
that as he continues to deliver on the
promises he made voters will reelect him
in 2020
so the RNC is skeptical of flakes
chances in 2020 and he was skeptical of
his own chances in 2018 I could not win
in primary that's the bottom line that's
because flake who was polling poorly
when he announced his retirement says if
he had to embrace Trump to win he'd
rather not run at least not in Arizona
for a Senate seat so what's different
now with a presidential primary well I
mean winning a primary in one state
doesn't determine what you can do
nationwide president Trump obviously
would never win the election general
election in New York but he's our
president flake might not come in first
in 2020 but he is the first Republican
contender to visit New Hampshire in 2018
president Trump hasn't even been here
yet but on Monday he is going to visit
New Hampshire for the first time since
the campaign Bret Peter Doocy in
Manchester I like saying that Manchester
Peter thanks